i don't like strip clubs why not
i ain't really trying to get no money to
look at you that's fair it was like
would you give money would you would you
if if you knew you could [ __ ] would you
then give the money i probably would
yeah if i had a for shoes well you know
in new york they just decriminalized uh
sex work so you can go to new york and
just you know pay for sex and it's not a
big deal i don't really want to pay for
it though i mean you're going to pay for
it either way right not really make them
pay
you can go on a date i make them pay
you make the girl pay on the payments
because i'm already taking them on dates
i gotta excuse them what's the excuse
i'm too popular so you won't take a girl
on a date anymore right ain't going on
all day
how do you get fraternized with women
see i got a big ass house come to my
house i just i just hooked one
is your house the kind of house like a
panty dropping house where like if a
girl comes over it's such an impressive
place
she's like i'm ready from the dirty
bikes the trucks the cars the the rooms
have you ever brought a girl over to
your house for the first time and then
went dirt biking with her i tried to
last night we had to catch a flight this
morning
oh